[Applaudissements]
bonjour j'ai mis les pieds dans ma
première guerre avec une énorme boule au
ventre
me plonger dans le noble dans le coeur
le plus noble de ce métier couvrir les
crises les plus violentes
celles dans lesquelles on va jamais ça
avait toujours été mon rêve depuis le
début de la guerre du golfe je
trépignais donc bureaux de
l'hebdomadaire courrier international
mais j'ai mis plusieurs mois trouvé le
courage de démissionner pour devenir
pigistes ou plutôt pour devenir moi
j'avais 29 ans pas un sou en poche
j'étais un peu bohème et j'ai décidé de
suivre une organisation humanitaire qui
partait pour la bosnie un peu à reculons
vrai dire avec l' envie de toucher ce
métier au coeur mais la peur de ne pas
réussir à supporter le voyage en bosnie
devait durer dix jours je suis resté
deux ans et demi j'ai été happé par
l'histoire
j'ai été contaminé par le virus de la
guerre dès le premier jour j'ai commencé
à travailler pour le figaro et très vite
ce fut l'engrenage jallet de village en
village de front au front j'assistais
aux opérations de purification ethnique
je pouvais plus m'arrêter je prenais des
risques de plus en plus grands je
n'arrivais plus à un arrêté est bien là
j'arrive plus à continuer
voyez les faits que ça me ferait ça va
revenir
désolé je redoutais ce blanc en fait et
c'est le blanc qui est venue des risques
voilà pardon j'arrivais plus à m'arrêter
je prenais des risques de plus en plus
grands j'allais tout le temps sous les
bombardements
je mettais pas gilet pare balles les
anglais m'appelait trompe la mort mais
moi pourtant dans mon métier
en fait couvrir des guerres c'était la
chose la plus excitante du monde
en fait quand on couvre une guerre on
voit l'histoire en train de se faire en
direct elle jaillit littéralement de
terre et quand on est journaliste
c'est vraiment le top mais il y avait
autre chose à l'époque aussi pour moi
c'était le meilleur moyen d'accéder au
graal le graal c'était le service
international d'un grand quotidien
national et dans ce milieu exclusivement
masculin je savais que pour acheter ma
place il fallait que je fasse plus et
mieux que les hommes et donc je fasse
exploser toutes les limites
je réalisais pas à l'époque quels dégâts
ça pouvait provoquer mais il ya d'autres
choses en fait aussi dans les guerres
les relations humaines sont complètement
démultiplier les masques tombent et
couverture sociale glisse les futilités
disparaissent en fait les gens sont
vraiment eux mêmes certains compenser
pour un jeu s'avèrent être des lâches
d'autres qu'on imaginait coire se
transforme en héros
contrairement à ce qu'on pense les
guerres ne sont pas fait que d'atrocités
les guerres charrie aussi des histoires
d'amour et d'amitié absolument
extraordinaire
une guerre ça extrait le pire de l'être
humain mais aussi le meilleur je dois le
reconnaître
j'avais aussi autre chose c'est couvrir
la guerre pour moi c'était un mode de
vie un mode de vie fait de liberté
d'adrénaline d'éclats de rire de nuit
entière à refaire le monde autour d'une
bouteille d'alcool local de folle
chevauchée en 4 4 en train de relier les
fronts c'était ça aussi ce mode de vie
en fait l'histoire est tellement forte
celle qui vient que j'ai quelque chose
en moi qui me fais arrêter
en fait je suis originaire de chamonix
la ville des sports extrêmes
j'ai arpenté la montagne depuis mon plus
jeune âge j'ai été élevé dans la nature
et dans la neige au pas de charge
j'ai perdu beaucoup de proches dans
cette montagne qui tue je n'imaginais
pas couvrir faire ce métier en restant
dans un bureau avec des horaires avec
une hiérarchie
pour moi c'était impossible
là c'est raté au fait
voilà
je vais rentrer dans l'histoire celle
que en 1992 un jour d'automne
l'histoire s'est retourné contre moi
j'habite désagréable la capitale de la
croatie je partage un appartement avec
une amie journaliste américaine et un
matin je me suis réveillé avec
l'impression d'avoir bien dormi et
d'avoir pour une fois échappé aux
insomnies qui ponctuait mon sommeil
depuis que je couvrais cette guerre j'ai
bondi de mon lit j'ai appuyer sur
l'interrupteur et la scène est restée
noir je me suis dirigé à tâtons jusqu'au
salon j'étais étonné qu'ils fassent
toujours aussi sombre et là mon amie
laura à hurler il savait loi trapèze au
tap and pay aux fesses
alors j'ai mis mes mains sur mon visage
j'ai senti ma peau brûlante tuméfié
gonflé je m'étais transformer mon visage
c'était devenu un énorme ballon tout
super ans je peux ouvrir les paupières
j'avais des balles de ping pong à la
place des yeux
c'était la panique
j'étais devenu elephant man qu'est ce
qui s'était passé pendant la nuit pour
que je puisse nous transformer ainsi
qu'est ce que j'avais fait ce que
j'étais allergique à quelque chose
est ce que j'allais étouffer les
médecins croates on exclut le dam de
queen qui m'ont fait une ou deux piqûres
mais j'ai pas dégonflé je suis resté
deux jours ont un appartement sans
pouvoir sortir en étant extrêmement
angoissés au visage brûlés je m'étais
transformer en un monstre et je ne
comprenais pas pourquoi
il faut dire que depuis six mois j'avais
pas arrêté j'avais enchaîné des enquêtes
et des reportages sans doute trop dur
pour moi j'avais passé deux jours sur un
charnier à mostar une ville à moitié
croate à moitié musulmane qui était
bombardée par les forces serbes
depuis les collines j'avais assisté à
l'exhumation des cadavres environ 300 un
gros bulldozer sortait de terre des
corps en putréfaction
certains avaient encore les mains liées
dans le dos beaucoup avaient été
assassinés d'une balle dans la tête
il y avait beaucoup de femmes et
beaucoup d'enfants quand je suis rentré
dans mon hôtel de split sur la côte
adriatique
j'ai dû jeter tous mes vêtements et
aussi mes chaussures j'avais pris
plusieurs douches d'affilée mais l'odeur
obsédante de la mort ne partez pas elle
était dans mes cheveux dans mes ongles
absolument partout elle voulait pas s'en
aller j'en ai gardé le souvenir olfactif
comme j'ai gardé d'ailleurs le souvenir
auditifs des bombardements je déteste
les feux d'artifice et puis j'avais
aussi travaillé sur la dégradation des
relations entre les croates et les
musulmans
c'est une deuxième guerre qui s'était
rajouter à la première plus connus entre
les serbes et les croates alors
évidemment quand on cherche l'amour ils
ont fini par la trouver
et moi je la trouvais à chaque fois je
me suis retrouvé pris au piège au fond
d'une vallée au bord d'un ravin quand
les croates et les musulmans commencé à
se tirer dessus depuis les collines qui
dominent l endroit où j'étais alors j'ai
dû ramper pendant des heures avec dans
la main droite mon passeport dans la
main gauche un mouchoir blanc que
j'agitais tout ça pour m'extraire de cet
enfer et puis j'avais aussi y travailler
sur les viols de femmes musulmanes par
les serbes de bosnie pendant des mois
j'avais arpenté tous les camps de
réfugiés de la région j'avais recueilli
des 10
deux témoignages j'avais toutes les
preuves qu'il fallait j'avais même ce
qui était incroyable réussi à parler à
des bourreaux eh ben j'ai jamais écrit
j'ai jamais pu écrire le papier c'était
absolument impossible en fait j'avais
l'impression d'être arrivé au bout de ce
qui est et racontable pour les lecteurs
mais aussi pour moi c'était ma première
guerre je ne connaissais pas mes limites
et la guerre c'est une drogue
une addiction dont j'allais mettre
longtemps à me guérir comme mon visage
s'est transformé en celui d'un monstre
quand je suis devenu éléphants schuman
qui rentre à paris j'avais demandé à un
copain qui viennent me chercher à
l'aéroport mais on sait jamais trouvé
pour fait qu'il m'a pas reconnue je suis
allée à l'hôpital saint-louis dans le
service de dermatologie et là on m'a
fait tous les tests possibles et
imaginables
on n'a jamais rien trouvé les tests
d'allergie étaient négatifs en fait
j'avais rien on a même envoyé des photos
de mon visage à des spécialistes
étrangers
en vain
ces séjours à saint louis gillet que le
matin en fait je les entrecoupait de
séjour en bosnie parce qu'en fait je
pouvais pas m'empêcher de retourner à
sarajevo l'appel de la guerre était trop
fort donc je pars tech de la cortisone
je restais 15 jours et quand j'ai été
obligé d'arrêter la cortisone avec mon
visage s'en remettait à gonfler et ben
je rentre à saint louis
cependant depuis assez assez vite quand
même j'avais suggéré aux médecins qui
visiblement était impuissant face à la
maladie que l avait sans doute des
origines psychosomatiques je leur ai
expliqué ce que je faisais la manière
dont je pratiquais ce métier ce que
j'avais vécu ces dernières semaines ces
derniers mois mais à chaque fois je me
heurtais un mur un possible disait-il
on n'a jamais jamais jamais vu une telle
réaction dermatologiques suite un choc
affectif ou émotionnel c'est impossible
alors moi j'étais désespéré en fait
parce que je commençais à avoir la
certitude que je pourrais pas vivre
longtemps comme ça c'était pas possible
c'était trop dur en fait je pouvais même
pas sortir dans la rue pour acheter une
baguette ça marchait pas j'y arrivais
pas
et puis un jour au bout d'à peu près
trois mois les médecins de saint-louis
m'ont conseillé d'aller voir ailleurs
ils m'ont dit dans d'autres hôpitaux
d'autres médecins auront peut-être
d'autres idées mais nous aux cales et
ils ont dit et si vous tenez vraiment
vos histoires de psychosomatique vous
pouvez toujours aller voir dans le
couloir d'à côté frappé à la porte de
madame untel
elle se prétend psycho dermato mais nous
on la prend pas au sérieux
j'étais absolument furieuse qui met k
c'est l'existence de cette femme si
longtemps furax viré du service j'ai
claqué la porte et je suis allé frapper
au bureau qu'on m'avait indiqué j'ai
résumé mon histoire en quelques phrases
et la spécialiste très naturellement m'a
donné rendez vous le lendemain dans son
cabinet privé
elle m'a juste dit trois mots elle m'a
dit 'il ne cherchez plus vous êtes pour
moi
la thérapie a duré moins de deux moins
quatre ou cinq séances au cours
desquelles elle analysé mes rêves et un
jour ou plutôt une nuit la maladie est
partie je vais vous dire comment je
laisse eu j'ai rêvé que j'accouche est
d'une araignée géante
ça vous fait rire moi un monstre au pas
devenu une espèce de mygales gigantesque
est sorti de mon corps je me suis
réveillé en âge haletante avec le coeur
qui battait à 150 alors absolument
persuadé que j'allais mourir sous les
piqûres de cette espèce de bêtes
imaginaires mais quand j'ai repris mes
esprits
j'ai compris j'ai compris qu'en fait la
maladie le mal était sorti deux mois
alors la dermato a confirmé mon
diagnostic elle m'a dit c'est bon vous
êtes guéri vous avez plus besoin de
revenir à laver l'air un peu étonné et
elle m'a dit pourtant quand je vous ai
vus arriver vous avec votre allergie à
la guerre j'ai bien cru qu'on avait pour
dix ans après cette histoire j'ai fait
beaucoup plus attention j'ai évité de
passer deux jours sur un charnier
j'ai pris j'essaie de prendre des
distances avec les populations locales
je me suis tu je me disais c'est pas ta
guerre c'est pas ton histoire mais j'ai
commencé un petit peu à me stabiliser en
fait j'ai commencé à avoir peur
la guerre devenait pesant tu
j'ai rencontré mon futur mari est alors
quand un journal m'a proposé d'aller en
russie et changer d'air en gros j'ai dit
oui ou plutôt on l'a dit oui parce que
mon mari s'était vu proposer aussi la
même chose donc on est parti mais comme
je le disais tout à l'heure la guerre
c'est une rock c'est une addiction et se
replonger dans à peine avais-je mis les
pieds à moscou parce que la guerre de
tchétchénie ont recommencé et j'ai été
happé le truc a recommencé jallet de
plus en plus loin de plus en plus près
des bombardements je pouvais actions
entend arrêter c'est une drogue en fait
j'avais besoin de la guerre un jour
pendant la chute de grozny et je me
souviens avoir hésité avec un ami de
libération la ville était en train de
tomber
je savais pas si je devais rester ou pas
tous les jours mais il partait je me
disais moi je veux bien rester mais
j'aimerais bien que le journal me le
demande alors j'appelle le chef de desk
à l'époque il s'appelait jean jacques et
je dis bon vaut jean-jacques c'est
stalingrad la ville va tomber tous les
jours n'est ce pas alors je pourrai pas
envie de papier puisqu'il aura plus de
téléphones satellites mais je peux
rester si tu veux et voilà ce qui m'a
dit ma d'isobel ce serait pas mal que le
figaro soit le dernier journal à rester
à grozny pendant la chute de la ville au
moment précis où ils présents ou wii
prononcez phrase une bombe larguée par
un avion tombe sur la pièce dans
laquelle je suis je me suis retrouvé
sous la table au milieu de la poussière
au milieu des gravats au bord du vide et
le téléphone avait été arraché de mes
mains par le souffle de l'explosion
mais je pouvais entendre jean jacques
qui hurlait dans l'écouteur isabelle dû
rentrer immédiatement
entre les avions les tanks les snipers
les hélicoptères la sortie de grozny a
été apocalyptique
je m'en souviendrai toute ma vie pendant
toutes ces années en bosnie en
tchétchénie
j'ai pas renoncer à ma vie de femme sur
le terrain j'étais un peu un gars ont
fait un mais ça me dérangeait pas parce
que j'avais été garçon manqué quand
j'étais petit mais dans ma vie je tenais
de refi j'avais eu deux enfants
magnifiques
j'avais beaucoup d'énergie et j'ai
réussi à tout cumulé même si je faisais
pas vraiment les choses de manière
orthodoxe
j'ai jamais pris de congé maternité j'ai
couvert la guerre de tchétchénie
enceinte n'importe nawak
c'est pas des choses dont je suis très
fier aujourd'hui pendant la guerre de
tchétchénie
j'ai jamais refait de d'allergie géante
mais à chaque fois que je franchissais
mes limites à chaque fois que j'allais
trop loin je devenais dépressive je
n'arrivais plus à dormir je pleurais
tout le temps j'étais fragile
j'avais plus confiance en moi bref ça
allait pas moi alors que je suis rentré
à paris j'ai fait une psychothérapie je
tentais qu'on avait un énorme besoin et
c'est là que j'ai compris c'est là que
j'ai compris après plusieurs mois de
travail d'où venait cet attrait que
j'avais pour la guerre j'ai perdu ma
mère quand j'avais 20 ans dans une
avalanche à chamonix
elle est morte en janvier mais on a
retrouvé son corps en juin seulement
après la fonte des neiges
je suis pas allée à son enterrement
c'était trop dur
j'ai préféré vivre dans le déni j'ai pas
accompagné mon père qui tous les
week-ends avec des bâtons de ski aller
fouiller la neige de l'avalanche pour
essayer de retrouver le corps de ma mère
ce denim a accompagné pendant des années
il a hanté mes jours et mes nuits et je
pense avec le recul qu'il a en partie
façonné ce que je suis aujourd'hui mon
caractère
ma personnalité en fait mais j'ai
compris en fait j'ai compris que en
couvrant une guerre je retrouvais ma
mère parce que je me mettais dans une
situation dans laquelle je risquais moi
aussi à mon tour une mort violente
à partir du moment où j'ai compris cette
chose fondamentale la guerre est devenu
beaucoup moins indispensable pour moi
j'ai continué à couvrir des conflits
l'irak l'afghanistan mais plus de la
même manière je franchissais beaucoup
moins mes limites parce qu'en fait je
les connaissais maintenant puis après
j'ai divorcé
j'ai décidé d'arrêter le reportage de
guerre ma vie familiale était devenu
trop compliqué et ça collait pas avec la
manière dont je vivais ma vie
professionnelle mais il y avait au
dessus autre chose
il y avait un appel qui venait de
l'intérieur de moi il fallait que je
change de vie alors au début je vous
cache pas que ça a été extrêmement
difficile puisque c'est une drogue
la guerre donc je trépignais à chaque
fois qu'un conflit commencé j'étais
frustré je voulais y aller j'ai été
insupportable au journal mon chef on
m'appelait nitroglycérine
et ça m'est resté en plus haut dans le
journal
alors j'ai trouvé d'autres expériences
extrêmes pour compenser comme couvrir un
marathon par exemple et puis après
quelques mois les choses se sont
apaisées
ça allait de mieux en mieux en fait j'ai
réussi à me sevrer de la guerre c'est
comme si j'avais fait une cure de
désintoxication
aujourd'hui je m'occupe des questions de
diplomatie de stratégie et j'adore ça
récemment un de mes copains au journal
qui a fait aussi du reportage de guerre
m'a demandé isabelle ça ne manque pas
d'aller couvrir la guerre qui commence à
mossoul un contre les djihadistes en
irak
j'ai dit moi absolument pas et toi
il m'a dit moi oui aujourd'hui je
connais mes limites je l' ai franchi
presque plus jamais je m'arrête toujours
à temps dans la plupart des domaines
j'ai mis longtemps à acquérir cette
connaissance de moi et cette distance
vis-à-vis du monde extérieur qui avant
on envahissait complètement les lignes
de rouges de chacun sont rarement les
mêmes et il appartient à chacun de
trouver moi depuis que j'ai identifié
les miennes ça va beaucoup mieux
aujourd'hui je suis persuadé d'une chose
quand on nous le relations extrême
intime avec l'extrême il ya toujours
derrière une raison profonde
elles remontent souvent à l'enfance la
découvrir est indispensable le processus
est long il est douloureux mais il
permet de transformer ses faiblesses en
forces
il permet d'acquérir une expérience dans
la vie qui sert tous les jours et
surtout surtout il permet de se libérer
à ce que les guerres sont aussi
intérieure
[Applaudissements]